julian assange sera-t-il extradé vers
les états unis c'est tout l'enjeu de la
deuxième et dernière phase des audiences
de son procès toujours détenu à la
prison de belmarsh dans la banlieue de
londres à partir de lundi et pendant
trois jours le lanceur d'alert devra
répondre aux 18 chefs d'inculpation dont
il fait l'objet
ils concernent notamment la révélation
de 700 mille documents classés secrets
militaires sur l'irak et l'afghanistan
la d'apporter à chelsea manning l'ex
analyste militaire pour obtenir des
documents sensibles ou encore la mise en
danger de source
opérant pour le gouvernement américain
des accusations que julian assange
ainsi que ses soutiens justifie par la
volonté des états unis à détruire la
presse libre depuis le début de cette
affaire partout dans le monde de
nombreuses voix s'élèvent pour demander
la libération d'assange
elle s'indigne d'une détention jugées
abusives et dénonce les agissements du
gouvernement américain en france deux
manifestations sont déjà prévues
aujourd'hui et lundi dans les rues de
paris avec pour objectif d'obtenir
l'asile politique pour julian assange
pendant ce temps le gouvernement
britannique reçoit des demandes de
libération des quatre coins du monde
lors de la reprise du procès lundi les
avocats de julian assange se relaieront
à la barre pour eux les états unis
cherche à museler la liberté de la
presse
s'il est extradé le lanceur d'alerté
australien elle risque jusqu'à 175 ans
de prison